When doing due diligence, what are the ideal numbers
when looking for backlinks and citations, et cetera?
Okay, so as part of the due diligence,
you guys have probably noticed,
and we've talked about this in the training,
that one of the things you're gonna look at
is how many backlinks do your competitors have, right?
And you can use this, do this with other tools,
but that's the wrong question, Jaylen,
and I'm gonna tell you why.
Not because you said anything wrong,
but because it doesn't matter how many backlinks they have.
What matters is the quality of the backlinks that they have,
and I'm gonna explain it like this.
If I were to offer you, say, 100 links from whatever,
random directory sites, whatever,
or I would give you one link from Forbes,
which one do you think would help you more, okay?
I would take the Forbes one all day.
Why?
Because unless one of those 100 is some crazy site,
unless one of those 100 is entrepreneur,
that Forbes article is gonna hold far more weight
with Google than 100 of these little ones.
Going back to the social example,
you being friends and homies with the quarterback
or with the student body president holds far more weight
than you being friends with all the ninth graders,
if you're a ninth grader, right, that are no-namers, right?
And again, we're just talking
about some stupid popularity contest,
but that's kind of what this is.
So it's not about how many, it's about the quality.
So what you guys need to make sure you're doing is,
yes, how many backlinks they have,
but the backlinks they do have,
how are, what are those backlinks like?
Are those good backlinks?
Do those have domain authority?
Do those have trust flow?
Do those have citation flow?
These are all things that we're gonna be getting into.
So it's not an ideal number of backlinks,
but what I look for is I'm looking for people
that are ranking, that have no backlinks is great,
but maybe they have three or four backlinks
and they are no follow-back links,
which we'll get into in a later video and into the training,
or there do follow, or there do follow backlinks
that have no juice or they're no follow backlinks, okay?
And they only have a couple of them.
So I, the question, how I wanna answer this,
it doesn't, it's not about how many,
it's about the quality.
And if they have 10 backlinks that have zero trust flow
and a little bit of citation flow,
I don't even view that as a big deal
because I can go and get one good backlink
and I'm gonna beat their 10 crappy backlinks
that maybe are no follow-back links
or maybe don't have any juice.
So amazing question.